all right good news
important news big news hashtag pulitzer
shefty reports
roger goodell has been vaccinated and
what what
and we'll be allowed to hug the players
who attend
thursday night's draft got to get that
bear hug got to get lifted off the
ground
got to get the the christian wilkins
flying
bump uh that was my favorite hey
you know for these guys who have grown
up watching it every year and truly are
brainwashed to think it is some sort of
an honor and a privilege to be
told have we done this before
no but i they're great i agree with your
stance but
the the brainwashed thing you're like
man we're they're brainwashed i know
well they are i know
they are who was the running back that
drove back like
all night in order to be at alabama's
pro day even though he wasn't working
out
that to me that now that is some
brainwashing right there
yeah those aren't your hairs yours we
don't need to do that dude you don't
need to do that i don't know
it's an honor and a privilege to be told
where you are going to be living and
working and who you're going to be
working with
even if that organization
is going to ruin your career because we
know that happens
we know that especially with quarterback
you go to the wrong team you go to the
wrong team
to start your career that's it it's over
ka put
so anyway there's nothing they can do
about it that's the one thing i've
sensed over the years
the players accept it because they are
firm believers in
focusing only on the things that they
can control
they can't control where they're going
to be drafted they can't control
that the rule is they don't get to pick
the team the team gets to pick them
joey bosa is the only one
who ever reacted to that question i
haven't asked it to
every guy because i've sensed that
the answer 99.9 of the time is going to
be i can only control what i can control
but joey bosa
miles however many years ago it was five
years ago did say
you know you got a point and i have
thought of that just like i got to
choose my college
i should be able to choose my team and
they should
well and especially if they are a good
player
like joey bosa is basically locked into
the chargers until the chargers say all
right we're done with you
if you are a good quarterback you know
you are basically locked in with that
team until such time that the team says
we are done with you and if you are a
first round pick
then that means that the team has five
years instead of your four years on the
rookie contract at least
and then they can maybe franchise you a
couple more times so
that's seven years of your life that are
basically surrendered
to the team that happens to select you
in the first round of the draft if you
are a good player and you don't really
get any choice in that so
yeah i frankly i absolutely agree with
you but i just thought it was funny that
you started with the brainwashing aspect
of it
i just i you know this time of year i i
i i
i can't help myself this time of year
mike man
i know i've been working here all that
long but i think i know that
but why what miles of all the people out
there
who cover the national football league
and there are thousands now
how is it that i'm the only one who will
say that
repeatedly i have i've converted some
people over the years
stats guerrero who used to produce the
morning show
at first when i explained it to him he
said i'm crazy i'm nuts i'm wrong
and after about four years of hearing me
all the time
i finally wore him down but and i don't
consume a lot of media but i
i'd be paying attention i'd know if
there was somebody else out there who
believes what i believe everybody else
is to shake the pom-poms for the draft
the draft is great the draft is awesome
don't do anything to change the draft
and i for me and then we're going to
move on because we got other stuff to
get to
i think part of it was when you have a
child
who gets close to the age of the guys
who are being drafted all of a sudden
you see your child
in the incoming players and you realize
that
you know they're not fully grown men
they're not fully formed adults
and if i was the parent of
a player who's entering the draft right
now and
we lived in an nfl city
and that team had a need at the position
my son plays
but my son had to just hope that this
arbitrary random circle puts him in
that's
it's wrong he should be allowed that
it's just it's like in no other industry
does this happen i'm done i quit
i don't quit some of you wish i would
quit i quit the topic for now
but i want people to understand that
from the player's perspective
there really is a problem with this or
just in anything they can do about it so
they submit
because what's your other choice you
can't bang your head against the wall
you want to play football
that's the way it works all right fill
in the blank with the 27th and now
31st pick in the draft courtesy of the
orlando
brown trade to kansas city the ravens
will what miles
i think the ravens will pick a wide
receiver and an edge rusher and i don't
necessarily know in which order they'll
do it
but i think those are two positions that
the ravens clearly
need to get better at look they lost
matthew judon he is now
with the new england patriots and that's
the guy that led the team in sacks the
last two seasons
been you know the ravens are the kind of
defense where they can get pressure
anywhere but i think
they could use one of these bonafide you
know the real
good guys that pass rusher that i really
haven't necessarily had since charles
suggs left zadaria smith he of course
is now with the packers so i think if
they can get somebody like that
with one of these two first round picks
they'd be very happy and i don't think
sammy watkins is enough of an upgrade at
wide receiver
that's definitely a position that they
need to address too
i'm gonna be far more specific than that
with picks 27 and 31 the ravens will
package them together
trade up to number 11 with the new york
giants because why not dave gettleman
seems to be desperate to trade down just
to prove to everyone that he's capable
of doing it
and with the 11th overall pick in the
draft they'll take the best receiver
available and at that point
it quite possibly will be devante smith
wouldn't that be something
if the new receiver in baltimore is 166
pound
devonta smith to be the bookend on the
outside
with hollywood brown and then sammy
watkins the speedster work in the middle
from the slot that passing game could be
revolutionized
quickly it could be but look i mean
i mean i don't know if they're going to
be able to do that is that going to be
fleecing dave gettleman man i think
that's one aspect of the [ __ ]
if that were to happen like that's some
that is some serious speed like the
chiefs have speed
that that's some speed to rival the
chiefs for sure
and and really when you're the ravens
and the free agents uh other than the
ones that don't have any other viable
options with all apologies to sami
watkins but it's not like he had viable
options
the only way you're going to get a good
receiver is in the draft when
the player can't say are you crazy
i'm not going to play in the offense
that never throws the football although
they throw it some
not nearly as much as other teams do all
right the new england patriots will
select
a what with the 15th overall pick
okay so i i think that they will select
the defensive back
they'll select a cornerback because i
think that that's going to allow them to
trade stefan gilmore
because it just seems like the patriots
have done so many things that are
not necessarily in character when it
comes to spending spending spending
this off season in free agency i think
that would be something that would put
them back in line
with where we usually feel like the
patriots are
because once they get a veteran that
it's you know starts to get a little bit
high priced
and then you also had some injury
concerns last year with gilmore
i think that would allow them to
comfortably move on
from gilmore maybe get a second round
third round pick back for him
and then the patriots would probably be
more in line with what at least i think
of how the patriots
would act uh in the off season and in
the draft mic
they have depth at the cornerback
position but this is likely the last
year for jc jackson
who got a second round tender as a
restricted free agent he'll be
unrestricted next year he'll likely walk
away what are you going to do with
gilmore
even if you have depth you're going to
need that guy i think best corner
available at 15 is what they're gonna do
and i'm not a big believer in them
trading up
i know a lot of people are fascinated by
that possibility to move up for a
quarterback
i submit that they love cam newton and
they want to see how far cam newton can
take them
with the benefit of a full-off season no
covid
and better weapons available to him and
that that apparently miles
is a very hot take for the opinion
generators in the new england area
because they all are convinced cam
newton sucks
and if you say that the patriots really
like cam newton
they they they think you're crazy
apparently well i mean
maybe that's just the reason why i seem
to i don't necessarily think that camden
sucks but i also just don't tend to
think that
they are uh convinced the patriots are
that cam newton is going to be the guy
that
can get them back to the promised land
so maybe i'm reading too much out of
boston and that's just influencing my
opinion too much
one thing we need to keep in mind about
cam newton
he has the perfect personality to follow
tom brady
and that part has been overlooked in all
of it but
when when he walked into the locker room
after brady walked out
it galvanized guys guys want to follow
him they want to get behind him i i
think the kova thing last year really
screwed it up and it's it's going to be
a very different year
for the patriots and for cam newton in
2021 all right the quarterback who could
suffer an aaron rodgers type slide
is who miles i mean it depends on
who you think is the second best
quarterback in the draft i guess you
know because that
wasn't that the whole thing about aaron
rodgers right but i the guides that come
to mind for me
would be trey lance first of all because
there's
not a lot of tape on him and so he is a
pure projection
so that's why i think that he could
easily slide but i mean if you
tend to think that these teams at the
top of the draft don't like justin
fields as much
then it would be him because if he
doesn't go
you know number four overall or number
three overall to san francisco depending
on which you know
betting favorites you you looked at in
the last week week and a half
then yeah i mean it could be justin
fields that starts to slide and you
don't really know when that slide is
gonna end
because in theory you know he seems like
the kind of guy who
teams should really be high on but you
know
all these different teams have different
kind of evaluators than we might be in
the media on the outside mike
yeah i i i tend to agree with peter king
that
five quarterbacks can be taken in the
top ten and i don't think any of them
will slide but if any will slide i i
think it's just in fields
and i'm not saying it should happen but
between fields and lance it would be one
of them and based upon
just the the overall assortment and
collection
of reports and opinions and mock drafts
not that i pay attention to those but
sometimes you can't avoid them
i i feel like if it's anyone it's justin
fields and then
i think it gets very interesting as to
who's number six
number seven number eight which of this
second cut of
quarterbacks ends up waiting the longest
and also
also when you've got chris sims putting
kellen monde ahead of
both justin fields and trey lance is
there a chance that if
field slides it's actually mon that goes
before trail or before justin fields or
even trey lance for that matter that
would be something if it happens
right the one draft prospect we're not
talking about enough
is who see i think it's jaylen waddle
and i think it's kind of interesting
because i mean when you just brought up
the ravens
and trading up talked about devonta
smith but and everybody's been talking
about devonta smith for good reason look
he won the heisman trophy
and there are these sort of questions if
you will about his weight and all that
he's 166 pounds which
i've had a lot heavier than 166 pounds
so
take with that what you will but i think
jalen waddle was so
good for that offense i mean if you look
at his numbers man i mean he has over
120 yards receiving in
the first four games of the season
before he gets hurt then works his way
back
to get on the field for the national
championship game if you're talking
about a guy
who really loves football and obviously
all coaches in the nfl want to see that
i think that's what that demonstrates so
i think jalen waddle
sort of like henry ruggs and jerry judy
last year where i think we all kind of
thought judy would be the first wide
receiver off the board
maybe he should have been maybe he
shouldn't have been i don't know
but at least from alabama right so this
is kind of maybe that same situation
where waddle could go
before devonta smith and it wouldn't
necessarily surprise me
i believe that if the dolphins
use the sixth overall pick on a receiver
and jamar chase jalen waddle and devonta
smith are
all there they'll take waddle so
i think you're on to something i think
you're on to something even over chase
i think the opt out at least from the
perspective of the dolphins
i think that may hurt chase and push the
needle toward
jaylen waddle for me and i'm going to
stay in miami but not with the local pro
team the local college team gregory
rousseau who we had on
the program last week at one point
uh there was that interesting
effort by someone to muddy the waters on
gregory rousseau earlier this week when
he in rapaport who's
who's clearly not a draft nick but he
had a report about what a tough
evaluation it is and
you know big tall skinny guy and
questions about this and questions about
that
he opted out last year when his agent
comes out and says
that multiple teams have told him that
this guy's a first round pick
unless in advance drew rosenhaus went to
gregory rousseau and said i'm gonna tell
a big fat
lie and it's not true and no first no
team has told me you're gonna be a first
round pick if this is the truth
then he does know it and he does trust
it and one thing that people don't
realize
the agents who have relationships with
multiple teams and they have
relationships because they represent
players throughout the league teams will
tell them the truth
and i'm fascinated to see where gregory
russo goes because if multiple teams are
regarding this guy as a first rounder
that means he's going to go higher than
people realize so
i want to see where he goes and i want
to see what he can do because i think he
can very
be a very good pass rusher in the nfl
miles
yeah i'm interested to see what he can
do as well and i think this is going to
be the thing with all of these guys that
chose to opt out of the 2020 season
and general managers i think at least
have been mostly responsible in saying
look you've got to take these guys
on a case-by-case basis because a lot of
guys did have very good reasons to opt
out so
when it comes to that and then you see
you know what exactly this guy has put
on tape how he looked in the workouts
all of that is going to be very
fascinating especially for an edge
rusher
and where he is going to go in that
first round
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports